hey this Steve we are gonna get started
in just a second here looks like I'm
having some network issues getting some
errors on the encoding side can you guys
see this alright and hear this all right
if you could leave a comment in the chat
that'd be super helpful
okay looks like looks like it's all
working now so welcome welcome back if
you were on previously we're now day
four of five working through our project
here developing an Alexa skill for free
code camp I keep forgetting to turn Alex
off every time I say that today we are
going to we're going to cover a lot work
we started talking about slots yesterday
and we are going to get into it a little
bit more today and talk about custom
slots so we're down here day for a
couple of other things that I talked
about yesterday I set up I pushed all
the code out to to github and so if you
go to github.com slash dabble lab
there's a repo called free code camp
livestream so if you head out there that
is what I'm looking at right now I've
got all of the the source code out there
that we've been working on along with
our dialogue yep earlier this morning
I've made some cleanups or I just kind
of took what we had from yesterday and
cleaned it up a little bit let me let me
show you what I changed just so nothing
is confusing for anybody that was here
yesterday so the dialogue we there's
there's three intents that we're gonna
work through here so I changed the the
example dialogue to elect well actually
I'll just play it so you guys can hear
it or Alexa open free code camp would
you like to learn about free code camp
here about our most recent medium post
or get answers to frequently asked
questions get answers to frequently
asked questions
there was an error the error was could
not find Pamela Alexa stop me yes so
that's where we're gonna pick up today
so we didn't get that implemented
yesterday but we we also what we did get
implemented yesterday was the medium
post and I changed that around just a
little bit to make it less stubbed-out
so Alexa open free code camp Alexa open
free code camp welcome to the free code
camp skill would you like to learn about
free code camp hear about our most
recent medium post or get answers to
frequently asked questions most recent
medium post the most recent article
posted on medium for free code campus
titled recursion demystify it's been
recommended zero times Alexa stop okay
so so that's really I so I didn't change
a whole lot I just kind of cleaned it up
a little bit so that it made made more
sense so we're gonna pick up today from
there and like I said today we're gonna
implement the dialogue let me eat let me
just recap what we did yesterday before
I get into this so yesterday day three
we Alexa stop okay so yesterday we we
talked about debugging and we looked at
making modifications to the skill
manifest and then we also talked about
beta testing and for anybody that filled
out that Google Form you should have
gotten an invite to beta test and if
anybody wants to do that that hasn't
done it already if from the the repo
from the read me page I put a link here
to complete the form to beta test the
skill so if you've got an echo and you
want to test the skill before it's
published live you can use the the beta
test link to do that okay so let's get
into Dave
or so like I said using slots so the the
functionality that I'm gonna get into
today is custom slots and specifically
what we're gonna do and we started
talking about this yesterday but didn't
get very far into it what we're gonna do
is we're gonna create a custom slot and
an intent for handling questions that
could be pretty much anything as I was
thinking about a little bit more after
we finished up yesterday a lot of the
the functionality that we would we had
kind of brainstormed two days ago a lot
of it was QA and so what I try to do is
come up with a way that we could go at
that where we could pretty much have any
kind of questions so sort of a knowledge
base that could expand and that is what
we're gonna try to implement here today
and I also mentioned yesterday there is
on skill templates calm there's a
template called
knowledgebase starter and so I'm using
some ideas from that for this but I've
changed it up a little bit for today so
some of the some of the code I'm just
gonna copy and paste in so we can move
through it pretty quickly but I'm gonna
start with the with the model and going
in here and what we're gonna do first is
we're gonna create a custom slot type
and we're gonna do that up here in the
the types section of the interaction
model and the the type that I come up
with here let me this is what I've
because there's a lot here so I'm gonna
just copy and paste this in and then
talk about it give me one second here
so so I've created a type called
questions and this is where we're gonna
define all of the questions that a user
could ask and we're also gonna define
'cimmanon synonyms for the questions and
what this is gonna allow us to do is
basically like if we've got one answer
we might have that answer might answer
multiple questions so for example if
somebody says wood is free code camp our
answer might say you know code camp is
dot dot dot you know it was founded dot
dot dot and founded by dot dot dot you
know we could have a lot more than one
response or one answer covered and so
we'll use synonyms to map different ways
that somebody might ask the question to
the same answer and the way that we're
gonna do that is with this ID here so
we're gonna have another file that we're
going to use so we'll add our questions
in here into the the questions custom
slot type and I've just got some
placeholder ones in there now but we can
we can build that out I've just got five
questions but this can expand
I think the upper limit for custom slot
values I I want to say it's 50,000 I'm
not 100% sure on that but it's something
like that so we've got a lot of room to
grow if if this got really big and was
changing often a better way to go at it
might be to use like elasticsearch or
something like that on the back end but
I think for illustrating what we're
trying to do which is really more Alexis
stuff this makes more sense so we're
gonna do it this way but what we are
gonna also need is a way to map to the
the answers and so what I'm gonna do is
a folder called data in
and in that I'm gonna have a file that's
just going to be a JSON file that's
going to to have my answers and I'll
show you how we're gonna do that quickly
so I'm gonna I'm gonna call that file
answers dot jason and in here and I've
only done one so far and then I've just
got some placeholder ones here so before
we built this out or before we publish
this live we of course go through and
add all the questions and like I've been
saying previously so if anybody wants to
help out with these questions please
please feel free to go out to the site
and grab some questions or add your own
questions and we should probably provide
a way for somebody to actually will do
that will provide a way that somebody
can ask a question that hasn't been
answered and then we'll capture that
question so that we can't answer it but
for anybody that wants to contribute
like I said before go follow the the
repo that I set up and do a full pull
request and we'll incorporate your
changes in there so we've got the
questions we've got the answers what
else do we need we need to define our
custom intent right inside of our model
so let's do that next we're gonna have
an intent that I am gonna call knowledge
base intent so we could call it like QA
and 10 or something like that too but
now I'm not racing to work so we'll
we'll go in here and got our recent
articles so we've got our knowledge base
intent and the knowledge base intent has
one slot and the slot name is question
and the type is questions so this is
what we just defined up here so when we
created a custom slot type the name here
is what I'm referencing down here and
then in the sample searches this is
you'll see when in the code for the
intent itself so there's kind of two
things that can happen here you could
just have somebody say hey you know I
want to search the knowledge base or you
could have somebody actually submit a
question and say you know what is free
code camp or any question for that
matter if we've got it defined so I've
got samples here where some of them are
just static like search you know take me
to frequently asked questions I thank
you and then I've also got the the slot
as just a sample as well and so we're
going to hopefully make this work too to
get our questions answered so now I've
got the questions and the answers and
for those of you have been following a
long you know now we need to handle the
the custom intent the knowledge-based
intent so I am going to see here what
are we gonna do we're gonna go in to our
index here and what do we got to do here
so we well for starters we need to
include the module right the QA module
do I have it I don't don't have that yet
but actually let me do that next so
[Music]
so I'm creating a folder for this is
gonna be just a local node module that
we're gonna use to query the data file
the answers JSON file and I'm gonna call
this QA Jas and this is going to and
this code is just exactly as it is in
the widget called the knowledge base
starter from skill templates comm so I'm
not changing any of this so but I'll
push all this stuff out to the repo so
you'll have all this code anyhow okay so
requiring here the native node file
system module and then also we're
requiring the the answers that I just
added back here earlier and then we've
got just one function in here that's
pretty simple it is returning a promise
but it's looking up to the to get the
answer based on the ID that's gonna be
passed and the ID I'll show you how that
is getting passed over by the Alexa
service so that's what we did find in
our interaction model here so this ID is
the ID that we're gonna be using to
query that Jason file with our answers
okay let's see what am I missing here
now I need to I need my handler
and let's do that now next so I did
modify this code this morning this is
not exactly the same code as the
knowledge-based starter but it's pretty
close and again I'll push this all of
this code out so we have it let's see
and did I include no so I need to also
include the QA you don't have to add the
J s but I like to because it reminds me
that it's local I guess I could see that
just from the path but that's why I do
that so we've got our QA we're getting
close let me talk through what some
what's going on here and the the
knowledge base handler so we talked
about the the basic intent structure
previously so I'm not going to go over
that again but we're going to be looking
for an intent request and the intent is
the knowledge based intent which let me
just confirm that I didn't change that
but I think that it's what we called it
right yeah so the knowledge base intent
and then in here so there's something
called entity resolute
which basically when you're using
synonyms it's going to look at
everything look at the what what the
request was from the user the the
utterance and then try to match it to
the to the to the right slot type but
it's going to be there there might be
multiple possible matches and so what
we're doing in here is we're going to
we're gonna be looking at the very first
match which I think is gonna work in
most cases we'll test it out but let me
show you that here so so basically it
could return if it matched if whatever
the user says matches multiple possible
answers what we're doing here is taking
the ID of the very first answer and and
then we're using that ID to get our
question rather the the idea the very
first question and then we're using that
to get our answer and we're building our
response from information that we've got
in our answers JSON files so this file
has the ID which maps to the question ID
and then the the answer is whatever we
want here and then the the prompt is
going to prompt the user for whatever we
want them to do next so like in this
first example which I built out its
handling the very first question which
is what is free code camp and so the
response should be free do this code
camp free code camp is a place where you
can learn to code for free they're
online challenges YouTube videos medium
posts and podcasts which would you like
to hear more about and this
I can't remember who provided that we
had it but thank you for whoever did
somebody provided that yesterday or the
day before so we're going to reap reap
prompt by basically asking what they
want to do next I think we're pretty
close to being able to to test this
let's let's see so deploying
all right I'm gonna look through the the
questions while this is building and
deploying and then we'll we'll test it
out and see how it's going we can set
the trigger
hey welcome mr. quality time thanks for
hopping in
so startup Santana you got your you got
your request is it working is the skill
working the beta test are you able to
say Alexa open free code camp looks like
this is deployed let's see if it's
working
Alexa open free code camp hello welcome
to the free code camp skill would you
like to learn about free code camp here
about our most recent medium post or get
answers to frequently asked questions
frequently asked questions there was an
error the error was could not find
handler that can handle the request oh I
just request requested Amazon echo API
dot request okay Alexis tablet so we did
forget to do something we forgot to
register the handler so we talked about
this yesterday too and I always forget
this that happens down here
[Music]
and I need to deploy again but this time
I can just deploy the lambda function
she'll go faster so this will just take
a second here okay there we go so let's
test this again Alexa open free code
camp hello welcome to the free code camp
skill would you like to learn about free
code camp here about our most recent
medium post or get answers to frequently
asked questions frequently asked
questions ask me a question like what is
free code camp what is free code camp
free code camp is a place where YouTube
videos medium posts and a podcast which
would you like to hear more about
podcasts hello podcast it's nice to meet
you Alexa stop so you can see that the
response that we're getting back on that
it's mapping to in our interaction model
a intent that we created yesterday that
Hello intent so basically what we need
to do is we need to go in here and we
need to do a question like
what what is you your podcast about and
then for some synonyms will go something
like this podcast tell me about your
podcast see do you have a podcast maybe
[Music]
maybe how often is the podcast updated
[Music]
ok we'll leave it at that for right now
and then I would go over into my answers
for number two and say the answer is our
podcast is called the free code camp
camp podcast that you can find on itunes
I'm assuming it is yes and
[Music]
and it covers stuff you'll love and then
down here like I said before this is
where we will re prompt them for
something else
maybe you will just say something like
what other questions do you have do you
have what other questions can I answer
and so now let's redeploy and try this
again so now I'm just deploying the code
actually I need to deploy not just the
code because we made a change to the
interaction model here and any time you
make a change to the interaction model
the interaction model needs to be
rebuilt so I can't just deploy the
lambda function I need to deploy the
lambda function and rebuild the model so
that's what's happening here this is
gonna take a second and again while
that's happening I'm gonna read through
the the comments so if you have any
comments or thoughts or ideas post away
okay let's see let's see
Alexa open free code camp hello welcome
to the free code camp skill would you
like to learn about free code camp hear
about our most recent medium post or get
answers to frequently asked questions
frequently asked questions ask me a
question like what is free code camp
what is free code camp free code camp is
a place where you can learn to code for
free there are online challenges YouTube
videos medium posts and a podcast which
would you like to hear more about the
podcast our podcast is called the free
code camp podcast that you can find on
iTunes and it covers stuff you will love
what other question can I answer for you
what about question 3 question 3 is the
third and 5 sample questions you can
also consider users to ask another
question for example what is question 4
Alexa stop so you can see how this works
we would just build out the knowledge
base by first adding the question to the
interaction model and a question like
what is Alexis stop good bye
yeah so we would we would extend this by
just adding the questions as a value in
the custom slot type that we called
questions and then we would have any
synonyms that would help train the
Alexis service on you know how to know
when somebody is asking something that
could be answered by our
answer which we would put in the answers
Jason file and all we would need to do
all you need to do to time together is
just post this or make sure that the ID
and the answer matches the ID in the
question and I'm gonna because this is
working right now I'm gonna go ahead and
just commit this in case anybody wants
to look at the code on github added QA
[Music]
and push that out so so you guys can
take a look at that in a second once it
is pushed out and the other thing that I
wanted to show you because we're we're
doing pretty good today on time we kind
of got into the slots a little bit
yesterday so a little ahead of where I
thought so we'll probably finish up
early today but I'm going to I'm gonna
see if we can do one more thing because
we've gots a little bit extra time here
I'm going to let's try this this
simulate command so so you go ask
simulate and then I think it's - T
actually it'll tell me give me an error
tell me what I didn't do yeah
- tax so so I'm gonna I'm gonna just
pass what is free code camp and I think
it's also gonna want a locale
[Music]
hmm yeah seems like we're knowing how to
do this I think it's again - you guys
let's see yeah how's it so now we're
testing and we're doing that from the
command and we got a unexpected error so
let's see let's say open
[Music]
let's just try open free camp see if
that works yeah so that did work so up
until this point we've looked at the the
testing in the developer council through
the web and through alexa through the
echo but you can and i mentioned this
earlier you can also test using the the
CLI i wanted to show you something here
the
so this is just a launch request but if
we if we change this up to be something
like I want to show you the entity
resolution part so ask free code camp
what is free food yeah see if this works
okay
so we got we got our answer back I want
to show you the requests though okay so
this this is the request that went from
the alexa service to our skill service
and you can see in the request the
question slot is being passed over and
the request type is an intent request so
this is and i know we talked about this
so i'm just recapping because we we've
got some time but the intent handler
about recent articles the intent handler
here is getting this request and it's
coming in as the handler input and we're
looking in here and they can't handle
method function for the type and the
type is intent request which is here and
then the intent name so request intent
name knowledgebase intent which is this
and then down here we're looking at to
see if the request has resolutions so in
here that's yes and then in there we're
grabbing we're setting this this
variable resolution to the the first
record in the resolution per authority
which is an array so here's that
resolution for authority and actually
there's only I think there's only one in
this yeah there is but if it had matched
to multiple possible values we'd be
taking the the very first one in all
cases so you'd probably in if you were
gonna roll this out live you want to do
a lot of voice testing and checking this
to make sure that the the utterances are
being mapped the right way but I think
that is probably where we're going to
stop for today
but let me just go look at our outline
here or maybe there's something else
that we can get in today using slots
multi turn dialogues that's a longer
topic so we're not gonna get into that
today
it's persisting to DynamoDB that kind of
goes with that so I'm gonna hold off on
that what we can do though is just
update we can do some cleanup stuff
right now on it so let's see okay logo I
saw this out here maybe we can just
[Music]
update the the logo and that kind of
stuff and we talked about where that was
but
[Music]
I thought I had one let's start a new
one so the the logo sizes are 512 by 512
pixels for the large larger logo and I
think 108 maybe I'll confirm that yes so
actually this works here
[Music]
I think I have it Alexa Alexa icons
small and what's up icon large yeah so
the large icon is yeah 512 by 512 and
the small icon is 108 by 108 and I think
I could just do like this I think let's
see maybe not
or maybe so maybe I just need to change
the background color
yeah but I need to know what color that
is so it's probably on here somewhere
yeah there we go and I'll do the same
thing for this and get these fixed up I
know this is not really Alexa
coding but like I said we got a little
time and I want to try to get this skill
as far along as we can all right
I think they can be peonies and
[Music]
save that and save this and then I need
to put these someplace so I'm gonna put
them on just in an s3 bucket it's
temporarily right now I think I've got
one if not I can create one
actually you know what's gonna be faster
[Music]
we can set this in here can also set it
in the skill manifest which is something
that we looked at yesterday also which
is normally how I do it but just for
time I'm gonna just go into the
developer portal and just do it here so
this here and a large icon oops
lunch and save that we're like really
close now to having it ready where we
could probably if we if we updated the
content we could probably publish it so
let's um let's do one final test and
then we'll we'll call it a day today
unless anybody has any specific
questions and we could spend some time
minore answering questions that are
related or even off topic if you want to
do that just let me know in the in the
chat alexxa open free code camp hello
welcome to the free code camp skill
would you like to learn about free code
camp here about our most recent medium
post or get answers to frequently asked
questions
tell me about free code camp free code
camp is a place where you can learn to
code for free there are online
challenges YouTube videos median posts
and a podcast which would you like to
hear more about the podcast our podcast
is called the free code camp podcast
that you can find on iTunes and it
covers stuff you will love what other
question can I answer for you what's the
most recent medium post the most recent
article posted on
and for free code campus Titans
recursively mystified it's been
recommended zero times so you guys can
see Alexa stop even though I'm asking
different questions some of them are in
our QA QA or some of them are handled by
our QA handler others are being resolved
to their own intent so so like that one
is a separate question right Alexa Alexa
stop and and we would we would probably
continue building this out like I added
some of the ideas that we had talked
about when we were first planning this
but some of the things that I don't know
if we'll get to get to Adam or not but
just some other feature ideas provide a
list of upcoming livestream events on
YouTube I think we could probably get
that one in let users listen to podcasts
I think listen to the podcast I think
that would be really cool and then
provide like a QA and coding trivia
functionality I think that'd be fun and
then let users watch videos if they have
like the echo show spot and Fire tablet
I think that we could get get that kind
of stuff in but let me let me show you
one other thing that I've added that let
me see if I can get it to do this Alexa
open free code camp welcome to the free
code camp skill would you like to learn
about free code camp hear about our most
recent medium post or get answers to
frequently asked questions how many
colors are in the rainbow ask me a
question like what is free code camp how
many colors are in the rainbow ask me a
question like what is free code camp
Alexa stop so one thing that I was
trying to do I don't have it working
completely yet was to set up a way here
where if the user asks a question that
we can't handle
and we would respond back with this
sorry I don't know I've sent your
question to one of my human co-workers
who can teach me the answer please ask
me again tomorrow and hopefully I'll
have an answer for you then and then
here we would capture the question like
to a database and probably email
somebody so that they could go in and
add the answer to our answers file and
add the question also that the question
is filed so that is functionality I
think that we could get working so let
me add that to our dialogue or our
future roadmap all right and I think
yeah I think that's gonna do it for for
today if there are if there are no no
other questions then thanks so much for
for for hopping onto to today's stream
and we will continue tomorrow and
tomorrow like I said we are going to to
cover multi turn dialogues and we're
going to also look at persisting stuff
to to dynamo DB so thanks so much and
hopefully I'll get to see you back
tomorrow
[Music]